you have to show us that the human could
be
stockfish 15 with night odds and you're
going to show us the way even if you're
a little tired
all right
so obviously don't listen to The Stream
you could always listen back
so far we've had three
honest players and um
expecting a fourth I know that will be
the case I'm thinking spinal's gonna
take it down no problem
spinal tap
here we go
good luck spinal
bring it home for the humans
all right
let's kick on the engine
let's see what we got
okay I think
we've had E4 game should I still stick
with E4
I guess let's see his approach to E4
a spinal is a beast if you're wondering
oh he's going with the the old Karo Khan
yep I mean 2700 land
Blitz rapid over 25 crazy house over 25
he's not
all right so Carol Khan
okay
two Pawns in the center
and deal with that let's see
let's see of course look at
E5
the big E5 Pawn
look at that Bishop outside the chain
still G4 down Knight doesn't matter
G4
okay
[Laughter]
have to question this bishop right we
can't let
I don't know we can't let what okay so
this is
it's only at -5 now so it already
start at -7
is this already a bad approach by spinal
E6
or Knight H3
I don't think I want to allow E6 to be
played
okay also h4h5 E6
hmm
what's going to be most uncomfortable
Knight H3
92
they both are just aiming for the F4
Square
92 it's saying the best move is Bishop
E4
Rook G1 and then E6
Bishop e397 Knight G3
hmm
likes Knight H3 E6 Knight F4 Bishop V7
H4
okay it seems
seems like we're gonna go with this it
liked E6 for a minute
Maybe
then queen queen D6 takes Bishop takes
you probably just want to still keep
this Pawn around so let's see what this
this wacky Knight H3 move is about
see what he comes up with I'm expecting
E6
he's taking a very solid approach to
Karo Khan
principled Bishop outside the chain
think it's a good strategy
White's gonna have to try and do
something stir up some trouble on the
king side
yakoon who hello another first time
chatter
nice to have you here
having some fun with Odds Games
okay Knight F4
C5 as the reply
I like Knight F4 better than Bishop G2
let's do it
see so right around now
black has this concern
this idea of h4h5
important sequence to be familiar with
this threatens to trap the bishop and if
you want to save it by moving either
Pawn mostly this one there's this
capture and problems quickly
arise on the
problems are going to happen on the
light squares G6
so let's see how he reacts to this
because two hello
another first time chatter welcome
all right Bishop E7 how does it feel
about Bishop E7 stopping H4 cold
says play H4 no matter what
or it says still play H4
isn't this a
um you know I think this is a hard move
to maybe assess
H4
as a human you're going to start
thinking wait and is that just poison
oh okay let's let's put it on
he's gonna think for a bit
it says you could take
or Bishop to E4 but then there's you
have to start weighing these open lines
and the capture on G6 you might be in a
pin that you can't get out of so easily
you might not be able to take towards
the center anymore because of this pin
to take like that
Maybe
see what it comes up with
I'm guessing there's going to be a
thinker here so this is a very important
moment
oh
he's not afraid at all
he said give me that pawn now I'm up a
knight in a pawn
I don't care about this half open file
you have
all right
all right
all right what's what's it what's it
chewing on here Knight takes G6
Rook H3
there we're gonna we're gonna grab that
Bishop
we now have an unopposed light Square
Bishop how is he recapturing
they could go in either direction I'm
thinking you'll take
away
from the center
but maybe he's gonna do the calculations
and say that he could uh he could play
this and glue the bishop in with H5
either one is still
still good for team black
oh on please fear he's a Fearless a
Fearless I am
he doesn't care about that PIN
he's seeing a way out there is a threat
to take we check and then win The Rook
so we could see now
a point behind Rook H3 it was calling
for that for a moment
Bishop B2 C5
queen of three
Queen F3 Knight H6
all right let's try this queen F3 move
it's defending the Rook so this you
could take with the King now
G5
a little bit of a dip
so this bishop is there to stay
not breaking that down or maybe maybe
you are at some point with F4
maybe he's eyeing up this maneuver
even if you win a pawn
yeah I think this is going to be a very
effective strategy he's he's gonna knife
in into those uh weakened squares
okay might have to work around a night
that's here Bishop E3
he's playing very fast too
it's not getting into time trouble it's
more time
you're ready to go Queen side castles
Knight H6
I don't know that Knight H6 is a move I
could see him playing
okay Knight D7
Queen side castles
Bishop D3
all right let's go Queen side castles
yeah this this might be something in a
in a way is this bishop maybe out of
play
if the Center opens up this is a
I don't know it's a short diagonal also
if there is this break I wonder about
you know the the center maybe being
blown wide open
okay 97
King B1 seems pretty standard
Rook H3 Knight G6
I could definitely see this one coming
up
Knight G6 King B1 at once Bishop D3
maybe yeah maybe bishop D3 make him
think about this one a bit more
hmm
I'm gonna go with Bishop D3 rather than
King B1 for right now
I think he might be looking for this
maneuver so
at least you'll have to think about it
you know do you want to end up with
triple Pawn triple isolated Pawns in
this bishop that is stuck
look at this guy
he's he's a convenient Defender to
neutralize this bishop oh he still goes
there Knight G6
not a top move
but he's still going there saying I'm
cool with trades
apparently capturing we don't want to do
that
it is liking the best but do we really
want to do that
gotta keep this guy no
or is the I I think yeah I guess we're
gonna take
I'm gonna try and
wow
all right what can you do
oh that's saying King B1 hang on let me
let it think still
all right let's go with this King B1
move
Queen E7 Knight df8
Queen E7 Knight D to f8
Queen E7 played
A4
or A3
all right let's let's just do something
that doesn't
I don't know
once more that one or A3
or A4 maybe we go with A4
let's go with this A4 top move
the moment
where is he going
in a way white is saying wait if you
make this decision you might have to
deal with this Pawn Fearless continues
to play Fearless Queen side castles
okay now it's saying C4
or A5
let's go with A5
I don't want to give this guy up for the
night
this is funny
uh no not not for this stream I'm not
really feeling up for any bullet games I
won't be playing any any more games
myself on this stream so
for this particular stream played early
on okay Knight F4 likes that as well
and by this point Okay so
well he is up a piece and a pawn
okay A6
or Bishop takes Knight
A6 it says best is F6
oh let's go with this A6 move
Thorns man thorns
it's playing strong moves and fast
that's a tough combo
to beat
is he finally gonna think
I don't if you take this Knight you're
freeing the bishop
so I don't know like
like
if I'm playing is is black here I'm
concerned like oh wait a second if I
take then I have to deal with maybe a
rook
or maybe this you know the queen here
and is this guy going to be out of play
so
let's play B6
B6
oh a big drop there minus four
compensation for the material
maybe or not quite okay now by this
point it is saying you know what you
better just take that night
all right at this I I guess we're Now's
the Time to take the night
we still have an unopposed light Square
Bishop we we've put a dent in the light
squares
all right so there we go
Bishop takes Knight
G takes and now what does it want to
play here still a a rook advantage
saying C4
explosive
C4
see maybe now this is where he's gonna
finally think there's tension
opposite color Bishops the extra piece
is this Knight
uh the quality of this Knight though
how good is the Knight
how's it looking from Black's
perspective I'd be concerned
you know watch out for me
who king move
it was calling for Knight B8
okay now it's calling for C captures D5
is this going to lead to way too many
exchanges
chop it says
chop and then Bishop B5
it's also saying Chop Chop Queen takes
F4
what if we just take F4 first
let me test something out Queen takes F4
Bishop G5 Queen F3 that's yeah that's
welcoming Rook exchanges I guess okay so
I guess we're
oh now it popped up for a second Rook C1
I prefer Rook C1 keeping the tension
yeah let's go Rook C1
maybe going into the game spinal said
you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna play
fast
and he continues to play fast because if
you get down on time it's
um tough tough tough
not easy
chop here
chop there and then Bishop B5
an alternative is Bishop C2 within B5
Rook H3 is another move
I don't want to release the tension
I think that makes life way too easy
hmm
C takes DC takes D Rook C8 Rook C8
Bishop B5
Knight f8 Queen takes F4 I guess one way
or the uh one way or another there is
going to be a rook Exchange
all right it is saying to exchange pawns
is there some other move only five
minutes left
hmm
okay I'm not going to do that I'm not
releasing the tension I'm going to make
a not so wonderful move here with Rook
C3
and go with the second rate
hopefully this causes problems
still want to keep that tension
Queen B4 considered best
maybe this one will make them think
are you gonna think spinal
if the bishop moves now
you could stack the Rooks
maybe then he'll be scared
okay
hey what's going on hey
G5
the bishop cannot Retreat anymore
Rook hc1
okay I'm gonna have to start moving
faster Rook hc1
the bishop is now cut out of the game
he's he's a very committed Bishop
it does tie down the queen
that likes Queen B4
it's gonna
crawl up into a ball maybe something
like this
within the break
Queen is observing this Pawn what's the
play after Queen B4 it says Bishop F1
it's finally thinking
Queen B4 maybe he's considering F6
I don't know about that
maybe there's a problem here
the E6 Pawn
it's night
under control
if you're just joining this was the
start position
playing down tonight
here we are 21 Moves In
he chose a Carroll Khan advance
I'm sorry Carol Conan
went the advanced variation
Bishop F5
okay finally he's thinking
so this is where this is where you make
a mistake finally after you think for a
little bit
I don't think there's a big mistake to
make in this position
would I play as black
maybe maybe this preparing that
or a capture and a push
where the structure can change
okay it's saying a minus six with Queen
B4
but still not entirely clear what's
happening with the queen before move
Bishop backing off and then there's
these Perpetual attacks maybe against
the queen
so you're going to come up with
this been two plus minute think now
Queen B4 Rook H to d8
Queen before it's saying King A2
and then B5
Rook B3 Queen A5 these you see these
these lines
I don't know
How likely are they
I think he might be regretting that G5
idea
poor Bishop
poor guy
you're stuck
problems
to solve here how does that Bishop
function
okay I don't have to figure oh here we
go F6 how's the what's the evaluation
now
oh we'll drop there a little drop
okay it says blast this position open
now as long as the queen could stick
around I think there's Perpetual check
ideas
it's at this point it says finally go
ahead and Chop on D5
um might as well do it now I guess
within this idea to
play F3 okay
yeah it's still completely winning for
black
do I have another way to keep the
tension it's not really
Queen E2 is another move
saying C takes D5
C takes D5 and then e takes F6
hmm
I don't think I have another Choice
really
hmm
all right gotta go
I'm going to go with this queen E2 move
still keep the tension
try and keep it complicated
see these these two moves are too easy
as recaptures
okay
chop
and now it's saying C takes D5
okay
Jake Jake thank you for the prime sub
six months now
thank you for your support
take like this take like this
six months sub but a four-year YouTube
viewer thanks man
I should have went ahead and captured
and Def and
should have went ahead with this
thinking at least
maybe this counts for something long
term put them under time pressure
what's he gonna come up with
you gonna go with this one
this is the most natural recapture
maybe he's concerned about checks in the
yeah that's what he's concerned about
this this this this
check and then Queen entering here okay
he took with the c Pawn
now it's saying Bishop B5 I have to pick
up the pace here
Bishop B5 it is
there a way he could go wrong
like is this capture
terrible somehow
maybe with this and then check and then
entering here possibly
I don't know let's see he's under five
yeah it is back to -7 which is where we
started
laughs
still alive though we got this queen and
a dangerous thorny Pawn
mate
he's a thinking
a knight and two pawns up
a long way away from
restoring that material
Queen H7 check Rook takes C3
now I could see him playing this one too
yeah but Queen check it's saying Bishop
back here and then where's the queen
going maybe the push
then this Pawn lives and the Knight is
boxed out for a little bit still
or maybe he's considering this one E4
decisions
there's still a wide range of moves
wide selection
tick tick tick tick tick under three
he's really chewing on this one better
make it good
E4
it's not a huge fan of that but okay
Bishop C6 probably an irritating move to
see there
keeping the tent the Rooks are still
alive this Knight is boxed out I don't
know Bishop here possibly
Rook takes Rook takes Queen here this
light Square might be a little
concerning oh
it's still minus seven
this bishop is still
not doing anything wonderful is he gonna
sack a piece
get rolling with these guys
have a we have a Time Edge now
it started with a minus seven eval
and it dropped to maybe minus four and a
half at one point we'll but back up we
go it likes F3 best also Bishop takes F2
are these necessary
is this a dangerous move
or is this an idea too Queen B5 hitting
the Knight hitting here looking for a
capture mates
he's only got a minute
try to keep it complicated
this was the start position
down at night
here we are
one minute warning
he's nervous
I have to do my best here in these final
final minutes to try and keep it
complicated keep the queen on what's he
coming up with what's he calculating the
chop here a push
Queen D6
bit of a dip there Queen C2
probably a tough move to meet
put it on Triple trouble
with this nearby
trying for trying to mate on C8
this guy is not around to defend C8
keeping the pressure on him
Knight F6
Queen B4
foreign
who's playing Queen before though
that would drop the Knight and then this
bishop
Rook Cafe
big drop there
under
-4 but
Bishop B7 Rook takes C3 Queen takes C3
Knight C5 not an easy continuation
let's do it here we are
critical moments here
Rook takes C3
Queen takes C3 Knight C5 and only move
Knight C5 is an only move he found it
only way to stop mate
take the Knight
opposite color Bishops but we're down a
million Pawns
Pawn takes oh no Elite chess is going to
restart in 10 minutes
Rook H1 Rook F1
Queen G7 is a dangerous looking move
really active
now we're looking at Bishop moves one
day and maybe mate
there's a lot going on here
okay
it's over
White's winning now plus 10.
oh
Plus 12.
Bishop takes D5
Queen takes D5 Queen takes f8
oh my goodness
this
still undefeated
he's trying King C8 not a fun move
oh man
Rook takes C it's a mate in 17.
with Bishop takes E6 or Rook takes C5
oh my goodness
oh man
so if Queen takes
what's the mate exactly if Queen would
have captured it's a mate in two
Queen takes would have been check
and then Checkmate here or here
depending on where the King goes
King d8 Bishop takes E6
what happens after this check
I guess you could fall back with the
Rook
Bishop takes E6
oh man
he must know he's toast he's he's known
it for a few moves now
no coordination
it's it's the queen
only one trying to defend and these are
all attacking somehow
they found a way
oh my goodness
check
Rook C1
Queen D3
King A1 maybe he still thinks that
there's a way to give a Perpetual that
is possible
and
oh there's going to be a bishop block
okay King A1
Queen takes A6
and now the bishop block
Queen D6 top move
Queen B7
threatening me
and C8
look at how close this is to be for to
be winning for black
ready to promote this this
promotion
okay Queen D7
now Queen B8
King E7 Queen E5
I can't believe spinal didn't see this
maintenance 17.
I'm joking of course
okay so now this bishop returns
to E6
he resigned
good game man
Round of Applause there for spinal
thank you for getting in the ring there
he was tired though in his defense he
was tired he said that beforehand so if
he if he's
has a good night's rest that would never
happen he's pointing out yeah exactly
your poor Bishop
[Laughter]
I thought I thought of that as soon as
G5 was in I'm like whoa wait a second
that's a bit of a short diagonal
tough game
real tough I was trying my best
sometimes I was making some sub-optimal
moves like this one here it wanted to
take like this or that
but I just felt it was going to simplify
too much I was trying to make you sweat
were you sweating
wow
and then
stockfish does the the Wizard stuff like
you would expect
it's crunching the numbers
let's see
good game thank you for playing spinal
you're gonna have to try another time
you'll get your revenge I'm sure
that was a well played game